- [Announcer] Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the main event
you've all been waiting for,
the release of iOS 14.5..
In one corner, Apple's CEO, Tim Cook.
In the other, the Facebook
CEO, Mark Zuckerberg.
(bell ringing)
(characters banging)
(characters punching)
(crowd cheering)
- Well, folks, that's gonna leave a mark.
Pun intended.
(crowd booing)
(cup clattering)
Uh.
What we're seeing unfold in this fight
is quite complicated.
In fact, you're probably thinking
what's this beef all about?
Apple makes phones,
tablets, laptops and more.
Facebook makes social networks.
Why the slug fest?
The simple answer?
Differing views of our privacy
and it's playing out big
time in Apple's new iOS 14.5.
But that's just the first round.
This is a fight that
could shape the future
of the internet
and certainly, the next wave of computing.
Yeah, it's a lot.
So I thought it was best to explain it
with the help of these guys.
No, you cannot buy these
because they're just terrifying.
(dramatic music)
Okay, let's explain this all,
starting with what brought this to a head.
iOS 14.5.
And a new feature called
App Tracking Transparency.
Now, for years, every iPhone
has had a secret string
of numbers inside it.
It's called the IDFA,
Identifier for Advertisers.
We'll call it your very
own ad tracking number
and it's used to help apps identify you
and know what you're up to on your phone.
So for instance, say Mr. Cook,
let's call him user 098002,
has decided to relax and
download a new meditation app.
The app records his number,
(app dinging)
and here's the thing,
the Facebook app and other apps
on his phone also have that number.
If that same meditation app wants
to try to get Mr. Cook
on its mega super relaxing
subscription plan,
it can go to Facebook and say hey,
let me advertise to user 098002.
If Facebook has that
number and there's a match,
boom, the personalized ad shows up
in Mr. Cook's Facebook feed.
There's another way this all used.
Say that meditation app
shows ads in its feed.
It can use Facebook's Ad Network,
which again uses that number
to keep track of your other interests
and feed you highly personalized ads.
So you get it.
These user numbers are good for Facebook
and other social networks
that wanna know what
we're doing on our phones.
And they're good for businesses
that want us to buy stuff.
But now with iOS 14.5,
Apple turns off that
ad tracker by default.
If an app wants to track
you using that number,
it will have to ask.
If Mr. Cook taps Ask App Not to Track,
then his meditation app
won't get his number.
Apple is giving companies a chance
to plead their case with
this area right here
that explains what the
company uses the data for.
Don't want those popups at all?
You can opt out of all tracking
by going to Settings, Privacy, Tracking
and turning off Allow
Apps to Request to Track.
All in all, this is Apple's big play
to give people a choice
whether they wanna be tracked.
And chances are, more people are going
to tap Ask App Not to Track.
And guess who isn't happy about that all?
Eminem, the rapper.
(upbeat music)
Sorry, I mean Mark Zuckerberg.
Our custom designs were rush ordered.
See, Facebook's business is built
on personalized advertising.
Instead of charging you to use Facebook,
Facebook charges companies to advertise.
These ads are targeted at you based
on everything Facebook knows about you.
Here's an ad Facebook ran
in The Wall Street Journal
at the end of 2020.
We're standing up to Apple for
small businesses everywhere.
Many in the business community
have shared concerns about
Apple's forced software update,
which will limit businesses' ability
to run personalized ads
and reach their customers effectively.
(bell dinging)
(crowd cheering)
(characters punching)
Facebook CFO, Dave Wehner,
was clear about how it will
impact Facebook directly
on a January 2021 earnings call.
- [Dave] We continue to believe
that that will be a headwind
in the ads business.
We're gonna have to be
providing a prompt asking people
for permission to use third-party data
to deliver personalized ads
and we do expect there
to be high opt-out rates
related to that.
- [Joanna] The company
added that the Apple prompt
doesn't give enough
context about the benefits
of personalized ads.
Still, while Facebook has said recently
that it won't have a big
impact to its own business,
Facebook seems to be acknowledging
that given the choice,
users would prefer not to be tracked.
A Facebook spokesman said,
"While Apple claims the
update is about privacy,
it's about forcing small businesses
and developers to charge for apps
that were once free,
hurting consumers in the process.
Free, ad-supported services
have been essential
to the growth and
vitality of the internet,
and we're joining others to
point out Apple's hypocrisy
and anti-competitive behavior."
An Apple spokesperson responded.
"Apps and advertisers can continue
to track users across apps
and websites as before.
App Tracking Transparency in iOS 14
simply requires that they
ask for users' permission
before sharing their data
with other companies.
Supporting small businesses
has been at the heart
of the App Store since it was created
to help developers of all sizes develop,
test, and distribute
apps around the world."
The company also says it has
introduced new free tools
for advertisers to measure their campaigns
while respecting user privacy.
As a company based on hardware sales
and more recently, more
subscription services,
Apple has long stood on
the side of user privacy.
Here's Steve Jobs in 2010.
- Privacy means people know
what they're signing up for
in plain English.
And some people wanna share
more data than other people do.
Ask 'em.
Ask 'em every time.
- [Joanna] And Cook has
taken over that mantle
and said this in January 2021.
- If a business is built
on misleading users,
on data exploitation,
on choices that are no choices at all,
then it does not deserve our praise.
It deserves reform.
At its foundation, ATT is about
returning control to users,
about giving them a say over
how their data is handled.
(bell dinging)
(crowd cheering)
(characters punching)
- But of course, there is
benefit to Apple's business.
Mr. Cook and his team see privacy
and other security features,
like encryption as a selling point
of its hardware and software combo.
So two men, two very
different business models
and two very different visions
of how technology and the
internet should work for us.
And the future fights are
going to go way behind privacy.
On that same earnings call from January,
Mark Zuckerberg said,
- [Mark] I do wanna highlight
that we increasingly see Apple
as one of our biggest competitors.
- [Joanna] He pointed out
products like iMessage competes
with Facebook's messaging business,
which includes WhatsApp,
Instagram and Facebook Messenger.
- [Mark] Apple has every incentive
to use their dominant platform position
to interfere with how our apps
and other apps work,
which they regularly do
to preference their own.
(bell dinging)
(crowd cheering)
(characters punching)
- But where's this really heading?
Literally our heads.
The fight for the future of computers,
augmented reality glasses.
When the tech is ready
and these aren't just big, bulky headsets,
these glasses will probably
run an operating system made
by one of these companies.
And it could be a fight
bigger than Android versus iOS
or Windows verse Mac.
Facebook, which owns Oculus,
is investing heavily in the
software and hardware side
of glasses, and is planning
to release some smart glasses
in the next year.
- I can't go into full product details yet
but they're gonna be the next step
on the road to augmented reality glasses.
- [Joanna] Apple is
working on its own headset,
according to various reports
and Tim Cook has shared his interest
in augmented reality for years now.
- And I think AR can help
amplify the human connection.
I've never been a fan of VR like that
because I think it does the opposite.
- So you see, this change in iOS 14.5
is just the start of this fight.
You know what's not gonna
be happening any time soon?
(groovy beach music)
As for who ultimately wins,
there's not telling
but at least with iOS 14.5,
the winners are users
who have wanted control
of their privacy and data.
Do you guys do anything else?
You just go to the gym all the time?
Tim Cook has the same
abs as Mark Zuckerberg.
They're both ripped.